mercedes recently brought out a new
mid-range coupe sedan
the cla 200 is large and sporty like its
big brother the cls a four-door coupe
our test driver matas kurat took a
closer look at the cla 200.
mata says mercedes always calls the cla
a mid-range coupe sedan but it actually
builds on daimler's compact series the
a-class matas is going to see how well
it fits the mid-range category
the car's big grill has mean-looking
headlights and large air intakes
graceful lines flow together everywhere
underscoring the car's dynamism
nothing here seems out of place
the streamlined rear has a dual exhaust
and a well concealed rear view camera
but inside our tester finds one
incongruent detail
he likes the dashboard and all the
instruments the language of shape the
vents the materials used are all lovely
but the display in the middle of the
dash for the radio entertainment system
and navigation sticks out like a sore
thumb montes is sure this could have
been better integrated
the interior design is very reminiscent
of mercedes sls the steering wheel
speedometer and decorative elements all
have a sporty feel
the design is clearly structured except
for the myriad buttons on the curvy
central console
it's a luxurious ride up front but what
about the back seats
mata says the back seat shows that the
car is based on the a-class and the
coupe like roof line means the back
seats aren't comfortable for tall
passengers
at least there's lots of room for
luggage mata says the cla's 470 liter
trunk really is mid-range level it's
only five liters smaller than the
c-class
for more sportiness in the cla you can
spend an extra 2 000 euros for the speed
shift transmission
our test driver is pleased overall with
the cla
the cla's handling really pleases mantis
who says the car hugs the road and you
don't even notice that it's a
front-wheel drive that's because the
power steering reduces the typical
front-wheel drive
in our field
our test car's 115 kilowatts of power
accelerated to a maximum of 230
kilometers an hour its eco start stop
automatic optimizes fuel consumption and
city traffic
mata's current summary
mercedes has really done a good job of
avoiding confusing the cla and the
c-class the clas and c have smaller
engines those with the same names are
simply a bit less powerful except for
the c200cdi and the cla200cdi
which have the same push
the two series are geared to different
people the c-class is the sensible car
the more versatile one but also a little
more expensive the difference in price
is between two thousand and five
thousand euros depending on the engine
size the cla in contrast is more for the
lifestyle-oriented buyer who plans to
drive alone
affairs with an auto
our the urban variant of our test car
with a 7-speed automatic transmission
cost thirty seven thousand eight hundred
ninety euros in germany the basic model
is available for six thousand euros less
you